this episode is sponsored by wandrium
make sure to stick around until the end
of the episode for some great video
recommendations
for those who have grown up reading the
traditional or canonical gospel accounts
about the life of Jesus it can be quite
jarring to read some of the
non-canonical texts that didn't make it
into the Bible they often include
stories and teachings that are very
different from what became Orthodox
Christianity and perhaps nowhere is this
ass chew whereas when we read one of the
most famous and interesting of all the
non-canonical books The Gospel of Judas
foreign
[Applause]
out of all the amazing archaeological
finds in the 20th century when it comes
to ancient Christian and Jewish writings
one of the most recent was the discovery
and publication of the Gospel of Judas a
text that turns the teachings of a
mainstream Christianity on its head and
represents a very different
interpretation of the famous figure of
Judas Iscariot the story of the
manuscript is a fascinating one in
itself it only exists currently in a
single manuscript written in Coptic the
actual Discovery is a bit uncertain but
it is believed that it was discovered
sometime in the 1970s in Egypt similar
to the nagamati texts that were
discovered in the 1940s the dry and arid
desert climate of Egypt is very good for
preserving all Papyrus which is why we
have found so much stuff there the
manuscript that included the Gospel of
Judas changed hands a few times after
its Discovery in the 20th century and
was sold on the Antiquities Market both
in Egypt it's about eventually also in
places like Europe and the United States
without anyone really realizing its
significance some Scholars had been
allowed to see the documents just a few
sections from it and did kind of realize
how significant this could possibly be
if it was authentic but it was never
allowed you know people the people who
owned this document wanted a lot of
money for it that the academic
institution simply didn't couldn't
afford and so for a long time the
manuscript just circulated in different
uh hands into in the in the sort of
Antiquities dealership markets without
being looked at properly by by
archaeologists or Scholars or people who
could preserve the document properly
among other things it was kept in a safe
deposit box in Long Island in New York
for 16 years which was a disaster for
its preservation unlike the dry climate
of Egypt Long Island is
not that so sadly the text was terribly
damaged and many parts of it are lost
because of this maltreatment it wasn't
until the early 21st century when the
text became accessible to Scholars for
the first time who after confirming its
authenticity realized what they were
actually looking at so even though the
text had technically been discovered
decades before it wasn't until 2006 that
the National Geographic published the
findings for the first time along with a
translation the text obviously made
quite the splash not only in these
scholarly Community but also Among The
Wider public which is not surprising
given how significant its contents are
the content of the Gospel can be truly
surprising to those who are used to the
stories and teachings from Mark Matthew
Luke and John just like with the Gospel
of Thomas we have known about a Gospel
of Judas for a long time
the early proto-orthodox Church Father
irenaeus famously wrote a word called
against the heresies in which he calls
out groups that he sees as heretical
including what we call the so-called
gnostics and in that discussion he
mentions a Gospel of Judas as one of the
texts belonging to this heretical
Gnostic Group quote
and Judas the betrayer they say had got
a thorough knowledge of these things and
he alone knowing the truth above all the
others accomplished The Mystery of the
Betrayal
through him all things both Earthly and
Heavenly have been dissolved as they say
and they reduce a composed work to this
effect which they call the Gospel of
Judas
just by reading this we get an idea of
the uniqueness of this text and many
scholars today believe that the current
Gospel of Judas that we have is the same
that irenaeus is talking about here
because when we read the actual text we
find that at least from one
interpretation it fits rather well into
his description
so what is actually in this gospel then
there is a tendency among people
sometimes to call basically all
non-canonical gospels Gnostic Gospels
which is often not very accurate
especially given how contested that term
is in a previous episode we talked about
the Gospel of Thomas which is often
called precisely agnostic gospel but
should actually or probably be seen as
belonging to a unique movement of its
own in early Christianity sometimes
referred to by Scholars as thomasine
Christianity so to call the Gospel of
Thomas a Gnostic Gospel According to
probably the majority of scholarship day
is kind of inaccurate because it doesn't
really fit into that category of Gnostic
teachings but when it comes to the
Gospel of Judas this is a text that most
Scholars agree can actually be
characterized as in Gnostic text now we
should remember that the terms Gnostic
and especially gnosticism are highly
contested historians disagree if these
terms can be used at all to refer to any
kind of movement in Antiquity and if so
than who or what should it be applied to
I discussed this topic at length in my
dedicated episode on gnosticism but we
saw there that irenaeus himself the
Church Father we mentioned earlier does
refer to a specific group with the term
gnostics and with the implication that
they seem to use this term to refer to
themselves so with this in mind we can
kind of use that term as a designation
for a particular School in early
Christianity which is often Otherwise
Known identified as the sethians or the
sethian gnostics and when we look at the
Gospel of Judas we can see that it seems
to align with the teachings and
cosmology of the sethiannostics in
particular and it is indeed often
considered among the writings by this
group along with other fascinating texts
like the apocryphon of John the reality
of the rulers and zostianos just like
the name suggests the gospel is to some
degree centered around the figure of
Judas is scary periods and secret
conversations between him and Jesus
the text obviously wasn't written by
Judas but it is named as such more so
based on its contents
and while the canonical gospels and all
of mainstream Christianity basically
sees Judas as the great betrayer right
the person who gives Jesus away to the
Roman authorities which results in his
execution he is of course therefore
probably the most hated figure in all of
Christianity but in the Gospel of Judas
a very different view of this figure
emerges one that gives a new perspective
on the passion narrative as well as a
new picture of the Apostles and the
purpose of Jesus's mission the gospel
begins with words quote the secret
revelatory discourse that Jesus spoke
with Judas Iscariot in the course of a
week three days before his passion we
then read a rather striking account when
Jesus walks up to his disciples as they
are praying and doing rituals of
Thanksgiving perhaps even doing the
Eucharist which
is weird given the fact that that event
hadn't happened yet but we'll see why
this kind of makes sense soon in any
case he walks up to his disciples as
they are performing these rituals and
praying and he simply starts laughing at
them and the disciples
perhaps understandably you are pretty
confused and so they ask Jesus quote
Master why are you laughing in our
prayer of Thanksgiving what is it that
we have done this is what is proper to
which Jesus then replies quotes I'm not
laughing at you you aren't doing this
out of your own will but because in this
way your God will be praised
this is a striking quote because Jesus
says your God does that mean that the
apostles are worshiping some other God
from Jesus yep that's exactly right and
this is the first indication that we are
dealing with a gnostic text here the
apostles here at least the eleven that
are not Judas in a way represent the
many Church fathers at the time when the
gospel was written that represent the
sort of proto-orthodoxies such as
irenaeus and which according to the
gnostics are Heretics that worship a
false god if you've seen my episode on
the gnostics you'll remember that they
reject the god of the Old Testament or
Hebrew Bible as a false and ignorant
pseudo deity called yaldabaoth or saklas
who fashioned the material world along
with his lower rulers or archons the
world is a kind of prison in which the
human being is trapped and Jesus is sent
as a savior from the true God of the
so-called invisible Spirit to help us
reach Beyond this material world and go
to the true world of the entirety
through knowledge or gnosis in Greek and
to the gnostics the ones who composed
this gospel the other Christians these
so-called proto-orthodox were leading
their followers astray by worshiping the
false Creator God rather than the true
God thus completely misunderstanding
Jesus who he was and for what he was
sent and the 11 Apostles in the Gospel
of Judas represent these false Doctrine
indeed throughout the text Jesus informs
them and us that they are misguided by
the false god that they worship and that
none of them understand who Jesus truly
is except for one
when I take a guess who it is
that's right it's Judas Iscariot the man
who at least according to the canonical
gospel accounts is the great betrayer
who was led and misguided by Satan to
betray Jesus and have the son of man the
Son of God killed this person this
Apostle this disciple in the Gospel of
Judas is the only one who truly knows
Jesus's identity and has the most
complete knowledge out of all the
apostles when Jesus asked who among them
is strong enough to stand before his
face only Judas does so
and while he can't look directly into
Jesus's face instead looking away he
utters the very telling words quote I
know who you are and from what place you
have come
you have come from The Immortal Realm of
barbalo and I am not worthy to pronounce
the name of the one who has sent you
this quote tells us a lot not only that
Judas does truly know Jesus's identity
but also further confirms the Gnostic
nature of this text
the so-called Immortal Realm of barbello
refers to one of the characteristic
features of Gnostic Thoughts with the
barbello being the first Eon created by
God thus the highest being in the Divine
realm and when he says that he is not
worthy of pronouncing the name of quote
the one who has sent you he is most
likely referring to the invisible Spirit
which is the name for the true God not
the false god of the Old Testament but
the true highest God who has sent Jesus
to help mankind the rest of the Gospel
recounts conversations between Jesus and
his disciples as well as secret
conversations between Jesus and Judas in
particular
Jesus continues to tell his disciples
that they and their successors are
basically villains who will lead the
people to false worship through a vision
that the disciples have Jesus explains
how they are like priests who sacrifice
cattle that is sacrificed people by
condemning them to false beliefs quote
they have planted trees in my name
without fruit in a shameful way
Jesus said to them you are the ones
presenting the offerings at the altar
you have seen that is the god you serve
and you are the twelve men you have seen
that is in the vision and the cattle
brought in are the offerings that you
have seen they are the multitude you
lead astray before that altar the 11
disciples really have a rough time in
this text but the role of Judas Iscariot
is a little more complex in their secret
conversations Jesus eventually tells
Judas about the complex cosmology of the
Gnostic system and many of the famous
players are featured here quote Jesus
said come that I may teach you about the
things that no person will see for there
is a great and infinite realm whose
Dimensions no Angelic generation could
see in which is the great invisible
Spirit which no eye of Angel has seen no
thought of the mind has grasped nor was
it called by a name
he then recounts many of the features
that we recognize from other Gnostic
texts such as the secret book of John
but a few things are different in the
Gospel of Judas compared to some of
those other Gnostic texts
Sophia or wisdom does not play as major
of a role here so in the secret book of
John for example it is Sophia one of the
eons in the Divine realm that creates
the sort of pseudo dividendity that
creates the the world the sort of
ignorant false god Sophia wants to
create something of her own without
asking permission from her male
counterparts and asking permission from
the invisible spirit and so she creates
a kind of deformed creature right which
becomes this this figure of the yaldab
oath or or of yelda both or saklas who
then creates the worlds and the archons
and whereas in other texts the names
yaldabaoth and saklas are used for the
same being the ignorant creator of the
universe here they are separated yaldaba
oath is a slightly higher being in the
hierarchy whereas succlas is an even
lower being that is responsible for the
creation of the world and thus
identified with the god of the Old
Testament or the Hebrew Bible but the
important part is not the details of
this Cosmic system but the Redemptive
and salvific nature of Jesus
there is a generation of people the pure
generation perhaps identifiable with the
seed of Seth and Gnostic myth that will
be saved through their correct gnosis or
knowledge whereas all other generations
of humans are doomed to perish but
unlike the Gospel of Thomas for example
which granted should probably not be
seen as a Gnostic Gospel to begin with
but there as we saw in that episode the
crucifixion of Jesus was not really
considered it was not an important
aspect of the mission of Jesus or the
how Jesus saves humankind in the Gospel
of Judas the crucifixion does seem to
play a pretty important role in the
salvation of humanity and what isn't so
fascinating about this text is that
Judas plays a very important role here
and in a quite different way from in the
canonical accounts Judas discusses with
Jesus how he has had visions of his own
where the other Apostles hate him and
treat him very harshly
this is an indication of judas's
important mission
indeed because Judas is special and has
more perfected knowledge than the other
disciples he has been given a very
tragic yet important task
whereas the other disciples will
continue to sacrifice to evil and to the
false God Jesus says to Judas quote but
you will exceed all of them for you will
sacrifice the man who Bears me in other
words Judas will help Jesus shed his
false material body and accomplish the
crucifixion as you can tell this is
pretty radically different from the
mainstream accounts in the synoptic
gospels Judas is the great betrayer as
we have said he does
there is a similarity in a certain sense
in that Judas does accomplish a
pre-ordained plan right it is the plan
from the beginning for Jesus to be
crucified that was what was supposed to
happen and Judas of course plays an
important role in making that happen but
in those canonical accounts Judas still
does what he does based on Greed and
being misled by Satan right he's
unequivocally an evil figure according
to those stories in the gospel of
judah's it's very different because here
Jesus explicitly gives him that mission
Jesus tells Judas that this is what you
have to do for me to accomplish my
mission so Judas doesn't do this for
greed or anything like that but rather
as the greatest sign of loyalty right
it's it's turned completely upside down
it really is the greatest sign of
loyalty because What Judas does will
inevitably lead to him being cursed for
all eternity by most people and still he
does it because he's loyal to his master
or Jesus who gives him this Mission it's
kind of a tragic story really indeed the
whole gospel concludes with Judas going
to the authorities as requested by Jesus
and ends with the lingering and haunting
words quote and Judas received some
money and handed him over to them
Judas is here a kind of tragic hero
sacrificing himself and his reputation
to accomplish Jesus's mission
this has led to many interpretations of
judas's role in this mythology because
it isn't exactly straightforward for
sure Judas is portrayed as special and
as having more knowledge than the other
Apostles after all being the only one
who knows Jesus's true identity and from
where he came as he said in the quote
but other passages also makes it clear
that Judas won't be saved and enter
Paradise either there have been many
interpretations by Scholars some of the
earliest ones looked at this text and
interpreted Judas as a hero
but as more fragments appeared and
further study was made opinions started
to change some see him as being
portrayed entirely negatively in the
text while the majority today see him as
a kind of neutral figure
a figure that plays an important role
but is neither heroic nor evil indeed in
an early section of the text Judah says
that he has had a vision to which Jesus
just laughs mockingly and says quote o
13th Diamond why are you so excited
speak your mind then and I'll hear you
out
what does this 13th diamond mean first
of all we should understand that the
term used here diamond is a Greek word
that does not correspond to our modern
idea of demon which is today always a
kind of negative thing according to
Christian theology instead here it is a
kind of designation for an intermediary
figure between Gods and Men Who are
neither inherently good or bad they can
be both good or bad so what he is saying
here is that Judas is some kind of
spirit you could say but things are
still very confusing in a later section
we find out a little more quote
Judah said Master is it possible that my
seed is subject to the rulers
Jesus answered him and said to him come
that I may something the text is lost
here but you will go through a great
deal of grief when you see the kingdom
and its entire generation when Judas
heard these things he said to him what
advantage is there for me since you have
set me apart from that generation
Jesus answered and said you will be the
13th and you will be cursed by the other
Generations but eventually you will rule
over them this is admittedly a very
cryptic passage but we can deduce some
idea of what he is saying Judas is the
13th Spirit or diamond
he has true knowledge of Jesus and will
accomplish the mission by handing him
over to the authorities which will of
course result in him being cursed by all
other people as Jesus said
but in truth he will actually rule over
them as the 13th spirit standing above
the other twelve thus ruling the created
world after the evil succlas and his
archons have been defeated by the true
God and the Divine world of the entirety
and the pure generation has gone to that
paradisal realm Judas at the 13th spirit
will rule the created world as a kind of
representative of the Divine realm he
will never himself reach that realm
himself but he has the highest position
in this lower created Universe there is
a lot more detail and a lot more
features to be explored in the Gospel of
Judas but just from this very short look
into the text you can already see how
much it differs from the traditional
canonical accounts about Jesus and Judas
and and the whole sort of passion
narrative but also how much it Alliance
particularly with the doctrines and the
cosmology of the gnostics and the sethia
gnostics to be precise in other words
this is a non-canonic text that you can
with good conscience call agnostic
gospel the text has made quite a splash
in biblical scholarship as you can
imagine but at the same time all of the
ideas expressed in the text can also be
found in one way or another in other
Gnostic texts too like the apocryphon of
John or or the reality of the rulers and
all these other texts that belong to
that group so the ideas themselves
aren't that surprising to Scholars but
it's still incredibly valuable and and
fascinating that we have this particular
gospel that is probably mentioned by
irenaeus and might have been a pretty
important text to the early gnostics it
turns the gospel stories completely
upside down portraying the apostles as
misguided and ignorant and Judas
Iscariot as the most exalted one even
eventually giving him a kind of cosmic
role as the so-called 13th Diamond it is
yet another example of how many
different ways people interpreted the
life and teachings of Jesus in the early
centuries it's really fun fascinating
how a preacher from Nazareth managed to
create such a significant movement which
eventually turned into the largest
religion in the world studying the life
of Jesus and his teachings from
different perspectives is one of the
most interesting things in the world to
me and now you can do so through today's
sponsor wandrium wandrium is an online
learning platform that brings you a vast
library of educational and engaging
content through a bunch of different
forms short form videos long-form
courses tutorials documentaries and much
more all the courses are led by experts
in their field and you can really tell
that mondium values scholarly
authenticity it's really great stuff
it's almost like having a bunch of
really good university courses that you
can watch from a single place and
basically from any kind of device too
you can watch on your TV on your laptop
on your phone you can even download it
as a podcast just to sound and listen to
it while you're on the go somewhere we
are working with wanjim once again
because it's really kind of the perfect
fit for this channel
learning and studying has aside from
being a great pleasure of mine has also
basically become my job at this point
which is an incredible honor and
pleasure in itself and aside from all
the books and articles that I read and
research through it's really great to
also have these really cool
engaging and entertaining videos and
courses as another source for
information and inspiration one gym is
always evolving their library of content
then they're adding new stuff all the
time it really is a huge library of so
much stuff so depending on what your
interests are there is most likely
something there for you for example
lately I've been trying to learn how to
read Greek and as part of that learning
process I've been watching a course on
one dream called Greek 101 which is led
by The Scholar Dr Hans Friedrich Mueller
which has been really really helpful but
perhaps of particular interest to those
who are watching this episode one gym
has just recently released a new 15-part
documentary series called searching for
the historical Jesus where the historian
John Pierre Esports walks in the
footsteps of the historical Jesus and
tries to give a perspective to his life
and Ministry I've seen the show and it's
really good even though I've been
studying religion for so many years at
this point there were still new things
that I learned by watching it I was
really mind blown by all the things we
know about the environment and context
in which Jesus lived which really gives
us an insight into who this person might
have been and what his teachings might
have been based on you know just knowing
the context in which he lived is of
course Central to understanding the
person and his ideas so if you're
interested in a look at the Historical
Jesus I highly recommend this new series
which you can find over on one gym and
if so then I'm very happy to report that
Ron dream is offering a free trial to
the let's talk religion audience head
over to onegym.com let's talk religion
or click on the link in the description
to start your free trial today thank you
so much to wondering for sponsoring this
episode thank you to everyone for
watching thank you to all of my patrons
as always and I will see you next time
[Music]